wir haben uns bisher in einer
trügerischen sicherheit gewogen es war
ein irrtum zu glauben auf der erde
würden nur sehr selten astor ihnen
einschlagen das gegenteil ist der fall
und wir müssen handeln jetzt links zum
science und fiction
diese meldung ist eine deutliche warnung
an die menschheit die erde steht unter
einem ständigen bombardement durch
gefährliche asteroiden
damit hat sich die einschätzung der
wahrscheinlichkeit eines einschlags
dramatisch geändert
bisher wurde davon ausgegangen dass zum
beispiel der asteroid von chelyabinsk
eine seltene ausnahme und außerdem nicht
so gefährlich gewesen sei das ist aber
ein trugschluss der az der letztes jahr
aufgrund seines einschlag winkels fast
komplett verglüht ist hätte in einem
anderen winkel eine großstadt komplett
zerstört verglichen mit der hiroshima
bombe hatte er die 40 fache sprengkraft
entsprechend tnt werden es 600
kilotonnen die atombombe über hiroshima
abgeworfen wurde hatte eine sprengkraft
entsprechend 15 kilotonnen tnt
es ist noch ein größeres exemplar
letztes jahr sehr dicht an der erde
vorbeigeflogen 2012 dh 14 flog unterhalb
der geostationären satelliten ganz knapp
an der erde vorbei allerdings änderte
der arzt dabei seine flugbahn die
heißt also groß von einem solch riesigen
himmelskörper getroffen zu werden und
auch nur sehr schwer einzuschätzen da
die asteroiden auch ihre flugbahn öfter
ändern das geschieht auch ganz ohne den
vorbeiflug an großen planeten zum
beispiel durch die einschläge von
anderen kleinen hast du eben immer mehr
wissenschaftler warnen jetzt vor dem
hohen risiko eines großen einschlags auf
der erde
wie oft hat sie in den letzten 13 jahren
passiert ist wurde erst jetzt bekannt 26
hast du eben sind auf der erde
eingeschlagen darauf gekommen sind
findige wissenschaftler
sie hatten die idee beim weltweiten
atomteststopp überwachungs netzwerk
nachzufragen ob es andere größere
explosionen auf der erde gab und es
waren 26 und es konnten nur hast du
ihnen einschläge sei nichts anderes hat
eine solche wucht und lediglich ein
einschlag wurde dabei vorher gesehen
alle anderen kamen im wahrsten sinne des
wortes aus heiterem himmel
jedes jahr schlagen also zwei größere
hast du ihnen hier auf der erde ein
bisher hatten wir großes glück denn die
gesteinsbrocken studien mehr in wüsten
oder sonstigen unbewohnten gebieten ein
und verdampften bereits in der
atmosphäre
wie hoch ist also das risiko wirklich
wie schnell ein asteroid oder komet auf
einem planeten einschlagen kann wurde
1994 deutlich der komet shoemaker levy
ist ein beeindruckendes beispiel
entdeckt wurde er am 24 märz 1993 und am
16 juli 1994 also nur gut ein jahr
später schlugen die ersten bruchstücke
auf dem jupiter ein
sie hatten eine sprengkraft von 50
millionen hiroshima bomben
der jupiter hat allerdings ein deutlich
größeres und stärkeres gravitationsfeld
als die erde also erzielt mehr an
aber trotzdem ist das risiko auch hier
auf der erde hoch millionen und
abermillionen gesteinsbrocken rasen
durch unser sonnensystem und dabei sind
die zahlen allein für unseren planeten
ziemlich beeindruckend es wird vermutet
dass etwa eine million asten sich im
bereich der erdumlaufbahn befinden davon
kennen wir 10.000 das ist exakt 1
prozent eine expertengruppe des united
nations office for auto space also das
büro der vereinten nationen für weltraum
angelegenheiten will dieses jahr
vorschläge unterbreiten was bei einem
drohenden einschlag eines asteroiden mit
einer größe von mehr als einem kilometer
getan werden kann
bei einem solchen anschlag ist mit der
vernichtung der erde beziehungsweise den
meisten leben auf der erde zu rechnen
zunächst konzentriert sich die
expertengruppe auf diesen armageddon
fallen eine idee liegt dort schon vor
kleinere asteroiden sollen zum einschlag
auf großen asteroiden gebracht werden um
ihre flugbahn zu ändern eine andere
gruppe will sich um die kleineren
exemplare kümmern die noch nicht einmal
gefunden wurden ehemalige astronauten um
den space shuttle piloten etwa wollen
asteroiden finden die zumindest städte
länder und kontinente zerstören können
damit sie frühzeitig erkannt werden will
ihre organisation wie fix 112 einen
privat finanzierten satelliten in den
weltraum schicken der die erste lied mit
einer kamera aufspürt
wir müssen handeln und vielleicht hat
die erforschung des weltraums hier auch
seine bestimmung gefunden das überleben
der menschheit zu sichern
mehr infos zu diesem thema und täglich
mehr sein
in der kostenlosen pixum app hier
klicken und das gibt es natürlich für
android und ios allerdings auch in der
video beschreibung und hier geht es zum
letzten video pixum science and history
über die grösste atomkatastrophe der
menschheit die kernschmelze in
tschernobyl ich würde jetzt
interessieren sollen wir wirklich so
viel geld für das auffinden von
asteroiden ausgeben oder wird das risiko
hier überschätzen diskutiertes in den
kommentaren also bis dann bleibt dran
[Musik]